[Musique]
pour conclure les festivités du nouvel
an chinois le département et la région
se sont associés afin de célébrer la
fête des lanternes
la fée dans une lion d'angers traque bon
et tambours de chang 6 2 bat peu partout
dans l'île
oui partout
n'est dû faire une cinquantaine
cinquantaine le lion a pas vraiment de
l'histoire si c'est juste une manière de
représenter
les traditions chinoises à la réunion
dont pour perpétuer cette tradition que
nos ancêtres nous ont appris
[Musique]
une mobilisation de toutes les
associations chinoises de lille qui ne
doit pas faire oublier le vivre ensemble
parce que plus que jamais il est
important que chacun se sent bien à
l'union
mon et un manque ablement térénez
l'inter est à la fois chinoise africains
européens malgré âge non plus que jamais
dans le monde
koné nous servir membres cela fut ma vie
du monde ne devons jamais oublier qu'à
quelques heures de chez nous il ya des
hommes et des femmes qui sont nos frères
après les discours une convention a été
signée entre les collectivités et la
fédération des associations chinoises
de quoi valider les trois prochaines
années de coopération
un moment d'émotion pour son président
savez c'est comme je le disais la
reconnaissance de travail qui a été fait
depuis des décennies par nos anciens à
nos parents c'est la reconnaissance que
nous avons participé pleinement les
réunionnais de la constitution de sa
société réunionnaise
je vivre ensemble n'est pas dupe et pas
une phase vérité c'est une réalité et
vous comprenez mon émotion parce que
c'est le la reconnaissance que le poids
des responsabilités
demain pour construire ce pont qui
conviendra de continuer des spectacles
expositions et ateliers ont conclu cette
après midi festive
une manière d'inviter les réunionnais à
partager une fois encore leur diversité
[Musique]